since it's been a fair few years since
we've last set foot in boulders gate I
thought who better to break down the
teaser then Larian zones fen vinca so he
has kindly volunteered to take us
through all the tidbits of mind flayers
and flaming fists alright so you're
seeing the city of Bulgaria to start
with which i think is its first 3d
rendition actually ever done and
actually that image is so it's gonna be
featured in the books of the tabletop
game anyway it does matter so then you
see a knight who belongs to a group of
mercenaries called flaming fist who are
doing law and order and the outer sides
of the city and into part what's called
the Lower City you have also an upper
city then you see that there's been
conflict clearly there's dead bodies on
the everywhere and then something's
happening to this Knight and he's
actually undergoing a version of what we
would call accelerated Serra morphosis
which is basically a way of reproduction
that these creatures called to mind
flayers have so let's take a tadpole in
people's heads that tadpole grows and
then it turns a human being or any
humanoid being into a mind flayer and
these mind flayers they are the guys you
know them from stranger things maybe so
there are these creatures which is
tentacles and they're psionic creatures
so they're they're very very very
intelligence but there are hive
creatures they have a elder brains that
command them and so they used to be used
to have an incredible Empire of the male
vampire and that spans many many many
planes and but it went wrong for them
and so they've been in hiding ever since
in a place called the Underdark
which is like the deep underground of
this world of Forgotten Realms and so
clearly somehow they've managed to get
people into Polish Gators are turning
into mind flares and you see some shots
where they're flying in the distance so
clearly it's an invasion of my players
also and at the very last shot you see
that big thing with tentacles there and
it's called a north load and that's the
thing that they used to have when they
were having their ancient empire with
through a kind of as think of it as a
spaceship that was capable of navigating
the the astral plane which is so yeah
that's what you're seeing so Knights
turning into mind flayer City and a lot
of time together party